what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
why hello there Rob Kaur welcome back
welcome welcome to the 420 second
Quidditch World Cup actually welcome
back to our another installment of how
to kill Super Heroes and this video
should satisfy even the most
bloodthirsty members of the Rob Court
because I know there are those of you
out there who just love killing stuff oh
boy here I go Kevin again and the reason
why is because of the fact that in this
video we're killing not just one but
five superheroes that's right five with
guardians of the galaxy volume two
hitting theaters this week I wanted to
bring you as much Guardian related
content as I could and as I thought
about which member of the guardians to
kill for a weekly murder session it
occurred to me why choose one when we
can take out the entire team so for the
first time in a history of this video
series we're going to tackle an entire
team of superheroes now since we always
begin with a rundown of each of the
various characters and their powers
we're going to do that with each of the
members of the guardians of the galaxy
and after that we'll move on to our
discussion on how to take them out now
with that said let's start our whole
video with the leader of the team
star-lord now
star-lord also known as Peter quill it's
simply the son of JSON of spartax and an
Earthling woman named Meredith quill who
as we know from the Guardians movie goes
on to become a space pirate before
eventually forming the modern
incarnation of the guardians of the
galaxy interestingly enough despite
being a leader of the Guardians
star-lord
does not have any superhuman powers or
abilities although he is an expert in
hand-to-hand combat and is proficient
with a number of different weapons as
well as being a master tactician now
star-lord is also made even more
formidable by the technology and
weaponry at his disposal most notably
his power suit and his element gun his
power suit greatly bolsters his strength
as well as his durability and allows him
to travel through space without any sort
of spacecraft and withstand energy blast
that would otherwise prove to be fatal
his element gun is his primary offensive
weapon and is unique in that it allows
him to shoot streams of any element he
chooses including fire water wind earth
lightning and Captain Planet
so despite his lack of powers star-lord
will actually present us with a
bit of a challenge due to his advanced
armor and versatile weaponry next we
turn our attention to Gamora
now Gamora was the last surviving member
of her species known as a zen wa beerus
who had been wiped out by the Badoon now
soon after she was found and adopted by
Thanos who was intent on molding her
into a weapon that he could use to
assassinate the Magus the evil persona
of Adam warlock now due to the Moores
upbringing by Thanos while it was harsh
she eventually becomes a very skilled
fighter and assassin as a result of it
as Stannis administer treatment that
enhanced the more strength durability
speed and agility through cybernetic
technology and also trained her in
martial arts from a variety of planets
and it's been said that she has become
an expert of an oddly specific 83.4% of
known fighting techniques now eventually
Gamora would turn on Thanos and join a
team known as the Infinity watch under
Adam warlock and later Peter Quill's
guardians of the galaxy team in addition
to her martial arts training Gamora is
also skilled with several different
weapons most notably a blade known as
the god Slayer which is constructed of
an unknown but unbreakable substance and
is powerful enough to kill the Magus and
pierce the skin of Thanos now if all
that wasn't enough Gamora also possesses
a healing factor which would come in no
surprise to us because it seems like the
majority of people that we encounter and
intend to kill all have healing factors
of some sort moving along we come to
Drax the destroyer who is basically the
literal embodiment of the internet now
something a lot of people don't realize
about Drax is that despite his
appearance he is not a member of any
sort of alien race and is in fact a
human named Arthur Douglas after he and
his family were murdered by Thanos
Arthur's spirit was taken by one of the
Eternals known as Chronos and placed in
a new vastly more powerful body for the
sole purpose of tracking down and
killing Thanos now much like Gamora Drax
would go on to join the infinity watch
before eventually joining the guardians
of the galaxy in terms of powers and
abilities Drax has superhuman strength
stamina and durability and is also shown
an ability to penetrate force fields
created by Thanos himself it's important
to note for anyone that may have been
familiar with the character of Drax in
some of his past incarnations and
wondering about some of his powers that
he had back then that Drax actually died
in the years prior to 2006 annihilation
event when we see him alive
and without any real explanation but
what is clear is it drags it's smaller
and less powerful than he had been prior
to this resurrection not only was he
bigger stronger and more durable in his
previous incarnation but he also had the
power of flight the ability to project
energy beams from his hands and could
sustain himself without breathing
drinking or eating however the current
version of Drax does not appear to have
these abilities next we come to Rocket
Raccoon who's basically just a walking
talking space record what I mean is that
we do not know the name of rocket
species but we do know that he comes
from a planet called half world and
takes offense at being called a racoon
but the truth is his powers and
abilities are basically that of an
ordinary earth raccoon speed and agility
a heightened sense of smell claws to
help him scurry up walls and trees and
the ability to take food from a dog bowl
and run on its hind legs in addition to
his work hoon based repertoire however
rocket is also a skilled pilot
proficient marksman and a leader with
tactical expertise that allows him to
lead the team when star-lord is absent
now finally we have Groot Groot is a
member of the floor colossi race of
aliens from Planet X which are basically
anthropomorphic trees that can only
utter sounds that sound like the phrase
I am Groot did the stiffness of their
vocal cords however those individuals
who spend enough time with florrick
velocity specifically those individuals
who spend enough time with Groot will
actually learn to understand he's making
a series of complex statements whenever
he says I am Groot which is the reason
why only Rocket Raccoon knows what it is
it is saying in the movies but despite
this limited vocabulary Groot actually
has a pretty diverse set of powers in
addition to your standard superhero
strength Groot is able to manipulate his
size in order to grow to giant size in a
matter of moments he's also able to
control plant life has a genius-level
intellect and can even create miniature
clones of himself but these are not even
the biggest obstacles to killing group
first we have to account for his insane
durability which you wouldn't think
would be a huge concern he's a tree and
all but in root case the wood he's made
up of is so dense that he can sustain
gun fire and even fire itself without
major injury furthermore root also has
the ability to regrow himself from even
the tiniest sprig of his body however
how long it takes for him to grow is
directly proportional to house
small of a sprig is left so even if we
manage to kill Groot we run the risk of
him coming back and so Natalie looked at
all the Guardian members and their
powers and so on and so forth and the
things that make them who they are we
can finally get down to the real reason
for why we're here figuring out how to
kill them
so just like we did before we're going
to run over each of these characters
individually but since we're trying to
simulate an actual battle here we're
going to employ a little bit of strategy
and try to find a way to take out the
easiest prey first and save the biggest
threats for last now keeping strategy in
mind our first target is going to be
Rocket Raccoon
I'm sorry Bradley Cooper but you gotta
go sure he's a return with a lot of
width a lot of tactical expertise and a
lot of skill with weapons but he's still
a raccoon
meaning that he can be killed in any way
a raccoon can be killed and really
that's pretty easy for anyone with a gun
and decent aim to do I mean sure he may
get a few shots at us he may even be
able to evade us for a while but at the
end of the day a well-placed shot from
pretty much any weapon is going to be
sufficient to take out rocket so that
was pretty easy but as I said they're
only going to get harder as we go on now
moving to star-lord not only is he the
next easiest to kill but if we take both
him and rock it out the rest of the team
will be left without a leader and
ideally in a state of disarray
theoretically making our task easier so
it's star-lord our biggest obstacle is
the body armor that he wears that make
him vastly more durable once we get past
that star-lord is effectively just an
ordinary human and him being half smart
oi does give him a longer natural life
but it doesn't appear to make him any
harder to kill than a normal human being
so how do we get past our Lords armor
well although to my knowledge it hasn't
been expressly stated how star Lords
armor works I think it's pretty
reasonable to assume that since
star-lord spends most of his time in
space it's likely that is all relies on
some form of technology to function
instead of just being a conventional
suit of armor especially given that it
allows him to travel through space
without suffocating so in order to take
it out we have a couple of options first
we can use a weapon that will emit a
powerful electromagnetic pulse or EMP
that should disrupt the electrical
circuitry powering star-lord since if
the suit short circuits or shuts off
then killing star-lord is basically just
a matter of killing a human being which
is only slightly more difficult than
killing a raccoon let me think about it
option for shutting off the suit comes
in the form of nanobots we see nanobots
used throughout the history of Marvel
Comics several of which were designed by
some of the greatest minds of the Marvel
Universe like Tony Stark or Hank Pym and
nanobots are simply just tiny robots
that are able to enter the microscopic
places and perform whatever task they've
been programmed to do and we've seen
them do things like show off the powers
of superheroes in the past so surely we
could get our hands on some of them
through some of the many nefarious arms
dealers of the Marvel Universe and then
use them to power down star-lord suit
and then just take them out by any
conventional means but with rocket and
star-lord out of the way we can move on
to Drax and Gamora and I'm grouping them
together here because for all intents
and purposes they serve the same role
and basically have the same power sets
they're both skilled combatants they
both have super-strength they both have
durability they both have some degree of
the healing factor they both primarily
fight with blades and they're both green
what I'm getting at is that in battle
they are pretty much going to serve the
same purpose so how do we kill them well
honestly even though they are more
formidable opponents in battle than
rocket or star-lord they can still be
killed pretty much however we want what
makes them troublesome is that they have
a pretty good chance of killing us
before we can kill them so before we
step into battle against these two we're
going to have to up our durability so
that we could withstand their attacks so
pretty simply we have to protect
ourselves through some sort of armor or
shielding then take these two out and
basically any way we choose decapitation
a blast from a powerful energy blaster
or whatever I mean they do have healing
factors but they haven't been shown to
be strong enough to recover from having
their heads separated from their
shoulders or being blown apart so I
think ultimately that would spell doom
for them now I don't want to sound like
I'm dismissing these guys as weak or as
if killing them it's going to be easy
we're definitely gonna be in for a fight
and we may even end up losing we may try
to engage them in combat and find things
going sideways pretty quickly but the
point is that theoretically for these
two we don't have to come up with any
clever or ingenious ways to kill them
they can be killed we just have to make
sure that we don't die in the process
and so finally that leaves us with Groot
ironically the only member of the
guardians of the galaxy to die in the
movie
now Groot is going to present us with a
pretty significant challenge and it's
for the very reason that we saw play out
in the first guardians movie we can kill
Groot fairly simply perhaps with an
explosion that reduces him to splinters
but we know what will happen any one of
those splinters can eventually regrow
into another group become adorable in
the process and sell more merchandise
than probably any of the other
characters in the MCU so far and we
cannot allow that to happen robb core if
we're going to kill Groot we're doing it
for real and for good I'm sorry baby
Groot you're adorable but you got to go
no dancing baby Groot no kid roots
threaten to press the blow up the world
button he has to stay dead so that means
that once he explodes we have to be able
to make sure that every single piece of
him is destroyed but how do we make sure
that happens
well can we incinerate all of the pieces
maybe actually said root is pretty
resistant to fire due to the density of
the wood matter that comprises him but
if we're dealing with small pieces of
wood here we may be able to do the job
with fire but the trick is that we're
going to have to do this
instantaneously because it's possible
that even one spore would be enough for
GRU to regenerate and so what we'll need
is an explosive device that will be
powerful enough to blow groot apart and
either incinerate or vaporize the pieces
before any of the spores can escape the
blast radius and of course as we know
the most reasonable way to do this is to
detonate a nuclear bomb in groots
immediate radius if we do that I think
that we can endure it once and for all
so that's basically what it takes it
takes a nuclear explosion to kill drew
and vaporize him in his entirety but if
you guys are new here to come this
explain be sure to hit the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and leave a comment down below let
me know what other characters you think
that we should do next in our video
series on how to kill superheroes and I
will catch you guys on it please
[Music]
[Applause]